so the official narrative of manson is
that from a young kid his mom was a
prostitute yeah
and he was just involved in a bunch of
petty crimes throughout his life in and
out of prison and he kept getting out of
prison and then
eventually there was one point where he
went in for seven years and then he came
out
different in 67 and he immediately
violated his parole
he was paroled to los angeles without
permission he went up to san francisco
to the bay area
turned up at the parole office and said
i want a parole officer up here they
looked him up and they said you're not
allowed to be here you've got to go back
to la they wrote to la
la demanded he come back he didn't and
then all of a sudden something happened
which i can't find the paper record of
the reason i have the records i do have
is i did freedom of information request
to the bureau of prisons
and i got a part of his parole record
for the
time he was supervised from his release
until the murders
which paints a whole different picture
he got assigned to a parole officer in
san francisco named roger smith
who was a criminology student at
berkeley and also a drug researcher
and working out of the haight ashbury
free medical clinic and that's where
things get really crazy um
that was was he connected to sydney
gottlieb
uh not that i know of but um
jolly west who was a psychiatrist who
went to leave of absence from the
university of oklahoma
to study the explosion of the summer of
love in 67 he somehow anticipated that
like six months before
he went to the hate he opened what he
called a hippie pad
laboratory described as disguised as a
hippie pad
where they put up you know posters and
he had grad students
he told them in january grow your hair
long i want you to staff this
hippie pad and we're going to study the
young kids that are going to invade the
hate
in the summer he knew this all in
advance and there's a whole reason
that i won't get into here about how he
knew it because it was well it was
basically
engineered by a bunch of these people to
happen in government
and jolly west had been
working in the cia's mk altar program
since 1953
which was a program that their ultimate
goal was to learn how to create
programmed assassins people who would
kill without recollection
or of not only the killing
also their programming and that was what
this guy's specialty was he was a very
well-known psychiatrist
and in the 70s 75
this information about this seeker
program mk ultra came
out because a state department person
who found the records
what was left of the records blew the
whistle there were congressional
hearings he was identified as one of the
cia
researchers who gave drugs to prisoners
to people in fake apartments to study
them
in the hayton in new york and a couple
other cities
and he was fingered but he denied it and
he was never investigated
at that point by 69 he had after 69 he
went to los angeles to ucla
and became the head of the psychiatry
department there until he retired and
then died
the year i started this book he it was
the year he died
oh wow and he was actually murdered by
his son
what well he was dying of cancer as was
his
wife and the son had
uh they were but his wife was a doctor
too
they had a family plan that if they ever
became terminally ill
that the son would give them
administered lethal drugs to them so
nobody knew it at the time
but after both of them were dead and i
think
the son waited a number of years there's
no statute of limitation on murder
but for this kind of thing i'm not sure
why but he did publish a book
in the early 2000s so they died and both
they died like six months apart his
parents were killed by the sun
and that was 1999 and the
sun published a book in about 2011
called the last good night where he
describes
the planning and the killing of jolly
west and his wife catherine
by lethal drug administration
um where is he now you want to know
that's weird so the son wouldn't talk to
me when i
before he wrote the book he said i will
never talk about my father it's too
dangerous he had too many secrets
i couldn't get him to talk to me then
the book comes out in 2012 or 13
where he talks about the rumors of his
father being cia but he doesn't say
anything more
it's mostly about just the human family
drama
of what it's like to have to be talked
into it by both your parents
and then to actually carry it out for
them i mean he got a lot of press he was
on good morning america you know all the
talk shows
so when the book came out i thought well
now he's gone public i'll try him again
but i waited a year or two
and found out he had died in the
previous year or two
and he would have only been about 55.
i can't find any record of where he died
how he died his two sisters neither of
them would talk to me
one's in europe and one's in new york i
beg them
to let me interview them so i don't know
what happened to him whoa yeah i just
found a death notice you know on
ancestry
and no record of him at any of his old
addresses that's so weird yeah yeah so
he didn't get any trouble for killing
his parents even though they wanted him
to kill them
he didn't yeah i mean i have the book
and i somebody asked me recently how he
got away with it
and i think it was something technical
like
he enabled them to inject it themselves
he gave them everything you know he did
all the concoction but he didn't do the
injection
something like that or so he said who
knows
he did it to a way you know he had
lawyers advising him and there was
definitely a risk of him getting charged
but i
think it would have only been as an
accessory
and maybe it was that that if it's only
an accessory
after a certain number of years they
can't charge you right rather than
the actual murder i'm not sure that's a
good question though wow what a crazy
thing
so jolly west was working at the haight
ashbury free medical clinic
which serviced the community in the
summer of 67 it was built to take care
of the needs of all these runaways
and it was opened by a guy named david
smith this gets confusing
david smith allowed jolly to recruit
subjects for his studies of hippies and
lsd
around the corner in his hippie pad
laboratory disguised as a hippie pad and
roger smith
who was the parole officer of manson
had manson come to the haight ashbury
free medical clinic where he was working
on his own drug
research and doing his parole and it was
during those pivotal two or three months
manson got out in march of 67. he was
just an ex-con you know he'd been
in prison half his life he was 32 i
think was 17 years
in and out of federal institutions for
dumb stuff like stealing cars and
robbing grocery stores yeah and he was
never in a county jail
except waiting for you know federal
trials
yeah silly stuff stealing a car and then
taking it across the state line which
makes it federal
the last thing he went to prison for was
stealing an envelope
from the mail which made it a federal
offense
so if that had been stealing
there was a check for 37 dollars that he
cashed if he had just stolen that check
and cash it would have been a local
thing he probably wouldn't have even
gotten jail time
but since he took it from a mailbox he
got a 10 year sentence
and that's we're going to go into that
more in the second book about
it looks like they wanted him in these
federal places for all those years and
even bullios he admits in the book
why every single time he committed a
petty crime
and you know stealing car is not that
serious that happens all the time but he
always happened to
go across the state line maybe just for
a few hours making it
and then come right back he said it was
weird bullios he admitted it well i
found evidence that
there were he he didn't go of his own
volition he had no reason to go to the
next state
but right because they were doing this
research in prisons
wow so i think well i don't want to say
it now because i haven't proven any of
this part yet but i'm
building a case now that he this all
began when he was still in prison
experimenting with him have you ever met